circumcision is the surgical removal of
the foreskin from the penis of your male
baby it is usually done within the first
few days of birth
at birth the penis has a protective
sleeve of tissue called the foreskin
covering the glans or head
the foreskin can usually be pulled back
to expose the glans of the penis by
puberty
according to the American Academy of
Pediatrics the potential health benefits
of circumcision include easier cleaning
of the penis decreased risk of getting
HIV sexually transmitted infections
urinary tract infections and certain
cancers and prevention of for skin
problems such as complications from the
inability to pull it back over the tip
of the penis
other common reasons for circumcision
are religious social and cultural
beliefs
before the procedure the area will be
cleaned the caregiver will apply pain
medicine either as an injection or as a
numbing cream
during the procedure a small slit will
be made in the foreskin and it will be
loosened from the head
the caregiver will place a device over
the glans this device will protect the
penis allowing the foreskin to be safely
removed if a plastic device is used the
caregiver will tie the foreskin to the
ring then the foreskin will be trimmed
the ring will be left in place and will
fall off in five to seven days leaving a
healed circumcision
if a metal bail device is used the
foreskin will be trimmed around the base
of the bail
the bail will be removed at the end of
the procedure
after the procedure it is normal for the
glands to be sensitive appear raw
and have a little yellowish discharge
if a bandage is used change it with the
diaper use petroleum jelly or antibiotic
ointment to keep the bandage from
sticking to the wound
it's safe to wash the penis gently with
water as it heals the circumcision
should completely heal within ten to
fourteen days